bonjour emmanuel dupuis merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct ce
matin sur rtl france c'est le premier
déplacement d'un ministre français à
bamako depuis le coup d'état d'août
dernier
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de cette
visite jean yves le drian écoutez c'est
une prise de contact le ministre aux
affaires étrangères n'effectue pas son
premier voyage à bamako mais c'est la
première fois qu'il rencontrera les
autorités de la transition
après de multiples rencontres qui l'ont
précédé et le ministre des affaires
étrangères marocain à mincir bourita
était à bamako il ya quelques temps sur
nos homologues sabri boukadoum algérien
également et le ministre français a mis
beaucoup de temps à venir à bamako
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
laquelle il ya beaucoup de discussions
qui vont avoir lieu avec les autorités
de transition on sait par exemple que
des divergences sont nés avec la
libération des otages des quatre otages
occidentaux et surtout les contreparties
des 206 otages djihadistes qui ont été
libérés par bamako
il y a aussi des sessions qui est en
cours haute autour de la question de la
vous parlez de la libération des
manières du pied il ya un petit temps de
latence entre nous et c'est pour ça les
aléas du direct vous parlez la
libération des otages justement savourer
soumaïla cissé 1 le leader de
l'opposition malienne qui a été libéré
au début du mois avec sophie petro n'a
justement concernant ses échanges avec
la libération de djihadistes il était
aux mains des djihadistes pendant
pendant six mois
quel rôle justement pour soumaïla cissé
est ce qui pourrait avoir vocation à
prendre à terme la succession l'actuel
président de la transition benneteau
alors excusé la discussion était très
mauvais je disais justement que c'est un
de tes sujets sans doute une des pierres
d'achoppement entre les autorités de la
transition et le ministre affaires
étrangères français la france n'est
soutien par la position actuellement
défendue par les autorités maliennes à
savoir d'un discours qui consisterait à
justifier une un dialogue avec les
autorités
avec les groupes armés terroristes on
sait qu'il ya eu une polémique à ce
sujet en france sophie patronat a dit
qu'elle n'avait pas été prise en otage
par des groupes armés terroristes mais
par des opposants au régime le chef
d'état major françois lecointre a tenu à
rappeler que non il s'agit bien de
groupes armés terroristes
je dis cela parce que les autorités de
transition disent de plus en plus
ouvertement qu'elles sont ouvertes
un dialogue en vue de la réconciliation
nationale et pour répondre à votre
question
soumaïla cissé qui a pourtant été prise
en otage que l'on six mois n'est pas au
contraire défavorable à cette solution
soumaïla cissé c'est bien que la
transition ne durera que 18 mois et
qu'avec le départ le 18 août dernier 10
des cas du pouvoir il reste celui qui
pourrait incarner une continuité
politique en tout cas c'est le principal
opposant
mais un opposant qui sans doute pendant
la transition sera très utile pour
justifier ce que nous français sommes un
peu un petit peu plus rétifs à accepter
c'est à dire cette ouverture d'un
dialogue avec les groupes armés
terroristes qui semble être en tout cas
ce que les autorités de transition ont
annoncé il ya quelques temps
quid justement du terrorisme dans la
région on sait que le mali fait partie
du g5 sahel cette transition politique
est-ce qu'elle ne fragilise pas
finalement bamako dans sa lutte contre
le djihadisme alors bamako n'est pas le
seul état qui est touché il faut bien
évidemment rappelé qu'il ya eu trois
mille soldats maliens qui ont été tués
durant cette guerre sept longueurs
évidemment qui a commencé en 2013 13 mai
civils 45 français faut-il le rappeler
et que évidemment les combats continuent
et de ce point de vue il faut avoir à
l'esprit que j'enlève le drian a
repoussé son déplacement à bamako
car ils souhaitaient se rendre près
précédemment à alger où il a rencontré
les autorités algériennes il y a aussi
le processus politique votre reportage
l'a montré l'accord d'alger l'accord de
paix d'alger qui a été signé en mai 2015
qui devait être totalement achevé en
2018 là pour l'instant été abondé alors
qu'à hauteur de 25% donc il ya aussi
toute une réflexion au niveau politique
qu'il considère devenait jean yves le
drian comme de ses prédécesseurs et et
bien évidemment les autorités politiques
régionales ne cesse de rappeler qu on
n'éradique pas les groupes armés
terroristes sans avoir une réflexion
politique et notamment sur la question
du développement c'est aussi un sujet
sur lequel le miz affaires étrangères va
insister la france fait partie des
principaux donateurs de dans le cadre
des opérations de stabilisation
d'ailleurs c'est aussi un sujet de
réflexion par forcément convergentes
entre les autorités régionales notamment
les cinq pays du g5 sahel qui évoque le
fait qu'il ya sans doute trop de
l'opération de stabilisation
il ya pour l'instant 17 programmes si on
considère les programmes onusiens
européens ou africains
l'union africaine a décidé d'envoyer
trois mille hommes supplémentaires au
mali alors même que tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'il faudrait avoir un
petit peu plus de convergence est ce
effectivement la raison pour laquelle le
g5 ça elle devrait être davantage
soutenu le g5 ça elle a été créée en
2014 et seulement 25% des sommes qui lui
étaient prévus qui lui étaient accordées
ont été concrètement mise en place la
ministre des armées florence parler est
également annoncée dans quelques jours
du côté de bamako
qu'elles peuvent avoir une répercussion
également le cessez le feu en libye qui
a été signée vendredi il peut y avoir
des répercussions au mali alors il peut
y avoir davantage de répercussions sur
les pays limitrophes de la libye est
précisément là où nos forces françaises
sont engagées dans le cadre de
l'opération g5 celle que vous rappeliez
c'est à dire le niger le tchad avec le
mali c'est un petit peu plus éloigné
disons que l'impact et surtout sur
l'algérie qui a montré durant les
dernières semaines sa volonté d'être un
acteur de stabilisation sur les deux
fronts avec évidemment sa frontière avec
le mali et puis bien évidemment sa
frontière avec la libye
je crois que florence wehrli raison de
rappeler qu' il faut impliquer les
acteurs régionaux dans cette logique de
stabilisation c'est la raison pour
laquelle le g5 devrait d'ailleurs être
élargi la question du terrorisme
n'impacte pas hélas que les cinq pays
dans lequel les opérations militaires
sont actuellement engagés et plus
précisément dans trois pays le mali le
niger le niger le burkina faso et une
réflexion est en train de se faire de
plus en plus évidente d'un élargissement
du partenariat pour lutter contre le
terrorisme je rappeler qu'il y a dix
sept opérations de 7,17 mission et
documents de stabilisation de projet de
stabilisation pour le sahel rappelons
que l'union européenne a engagé une
opération
enfin une mission fine un projet en vue
de stabiliser la question du sahel en
2011 et que bien évidemment la question
du seuil n'est pas la seule puisque le
sahel est au coeur d'un dispositif qui
englobe l'ensemble de l'afrique de
l'ouest
merci emmanuel dupuis d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'épaisseur d'instituts
prospective et sécurité en europe